[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien manger c'est quoi pour vous bien
manger pour moi c'est le plaisir des
papilles c'est prendre soin de ma santé
c'est avoir de l'énergie
c'est aussi la convivialité si possible
mais c'est aussi une contrainte ça
demande du temps ça peut aussi demander
un budget souvenons nous que pendant des
siècles bien manger était manger à sa
faim
et ça existe encore malheureusement
maintenant dans les pays industriels les
magasins proposent plein de produits
prêts à consommer il ya aussi la
restauration collective
c'est pratique quand on est pressé
d'ailleurs j'en profite pour vous
demander savez vous combien nous avons
le droit de friture par semaine je vous
aide une 3 ou 5
beaucoup sont étonnés d'apprendre et
surtout les jeunes qu'on ne doit pas
consommer plus d'une friture par semaine
pas plus d'une friture par semaine bien
manger remplir son ventre est devenu
facile mais avec quoi
alors maintenant vous nous propose plein
de régime on sait que le régime ne
fonctionne pas sur le long terme
qui dit régimes dits frustration est
donc impossible sur le long terme qui
dirige il peut dire alimentation
déséquilibrée et donc dangereux sur le
long terme
il y a aussi les professionnels de la
santé qui vous accompagne pour changer
vos habitudes de vie et vos habitudes
alimentaires et
il y à internet internet nous apporte
plein plein plein plein plein
d'informations le microbiote l'acide au
basique
le gluten et bien d'autres là aussi si
l'alimentation est déséquilibré ça peut
être dangereux sur le long terme même si
au départ on se sent mieux
est ce parce que j'ai choisi une
nouvelle alimentation ou parce que j'ai
enlevé plein de produits industriels
j'ai moi-même été ce qu'on nomme en
anglais une lcl ci veut dire prendre
soin de sa santé au quotidien et par
l'alimentation
mon entourage qui s'inquiétaient pour
moi parce que je vais peut-être un petit
peu à l'excès a fait des recherches et
dans le domaine médical ça a un nom hors
tôt rexie l'obsession de manger sain moi
ce que j'ai aimé dans cette alimentation
c'est que j'ai découvert plein
d'aliments une multitude de noix une
multitude de poids une multitude de
racine les patates douces certes mais
aussi le cas manioc les topinambours des
boissons le keffieh
je continue à les faire découvrir à mon
entourage d'ailleurs j'observe que
l'offre dans les magasins a changé
certainement à la demande de la
population serait ce notre pouvoir de
consomm acteur qui est à l'oeuvre
d'ailleurs les recommandations
nationales évolue aussi
vous connaissez mangez bougez cinq
fruits et légumes c'est le plan national
nutrition santé dans les nouvelles
recommandations 2010 est 2021
on nous recommande de consommer une
poignée de fruits à coques de noix à
nantes sans sel évidemment par jour on
nous recommande aussi de mettre au moins
deux fois par semaine des légumes secs
des poids des haricots à ce sujet savez
vous qu'il faut les faire tremper toute
une nuit dans de l'eau froide
jetez l'eau avant de les mettre à cuire
c'est pour enlever l'acide phytique un
anti nutriments on nous recommande aussi
de diminuer notre consommation de viande
rouge et de poissons
et les recommandations au niveau des
produits laitiers sont passés de 3 4 à 2
les recommandations nationales évolue le
lac ces robes la proche auprès du
patient évolue aussi et il y a quatre
ans je me suis formé à l'éducation
thérapeutique du patient
cette approche
ça transforme et d'un levier cette
approche on part du patient
de son point de vue de ceux qui le
motive
on est conscients des étapes du
changement c'est la roue de pro chasse
cas il peut être entré contemplation ils
ne se sentent pas concernés
il peut être en réflexion en décision en
action il est en train de faire ou en
maintien lorsqu'il est dans la période
de maintien qu'il est en action et qui
continue l'action deux issues soit le
patient effectué cette nouvelle
alimentation quotidien et c'est la
réussite soit c'est l'échec
l'échec fait partie de cet
accompagnement pour moi c'était très
difficile
c'était très difficile de voir que des
personnes qui voulaient changer leurs
habitudes de vie n'y arrivait pas
c'était aussi pour moi très difficile ne
se rendre compte que certaines personnes
ne se sentaient pas concernés
très difficile de se rendre compte que
des personnes trouvé cela contraignant
et ce dès du détruisez la santé en
mangeant n'importe comment
que pouvais je faire de plus que pouvais
je faire de plus alors j'en ai parlé à
mes amis j'en ai parlé aux associations
que je fréquente et j'en ai parlé aux
fab lab de jarry vous connaissez les fab
lab pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas les
fab lab sont présents partout dans le
monde
c'est un lieu des changes où il y à du
matériel mis en commun et surtout où des
personnes mettent en commun leurs
compétences et leurs idées au service du
projet sous la base du volontariat
bien sûr et imaginez-vous qui est un
maquettiste un graphiste du fab lab
accroche sur mon idée rendre un message
diététiques simples et ludiques pour qu
apprendre à bien manger soit amusant et
on travaille sur mon premier projet un
serious game comme ils disent je vous
explique
vous avez un jeu de cartes vous pouvez
l'emmener partout avec vous et on a une
mission par jour la mission exprimé dans
des mots simples accessibles à tous et
avec un peu d'humour
on essaye d'effectuer cette mission et
est ce que pour vous c'était naturel
plaisant difficile ou horrible alors une
mission par jour on avance pas à pas une
mission par jour si je le souhaite pas
forcément tous les jours cette mission
si vous l'acceptez non pas celle ci pas
celle ci celle-ci celle là
ne pas grignoter entre les repas
celle-ci gelade or il suffit lorsqu on
amène quelque chose à ta bouche de
penser à compter le nombre de bouchées
et instantanément
notre fonctionnement change notre
attitude change c'est magique donc pas à
pas on change nos habitudes en s'amusant
parce que trouver son alimentation
le bien manger qui nous correspond
lorsqu'on sait s'organiser
lorsqu on a plaisir à ce que l'on mange
et lorsqu'on garde la convivialité on a
tout à y gagner
la santé et le souffle le bien-être le
moral on a tout à y gagner tout pas tout
pas les kilos ne serait ce pas de notre
responsabilité que de choisir le
meilleur pour notre santé pour nos
enfants pour notre île pour notre
planète
alors c'est quoi pour vous bien manger
moi j'ai choisi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]